A WEAPON SIL O ONE USED IN DE.
RICHAR TMU FINING ME TONIGHT.
>> YES, 'A
TTS POIOS O H, SHCT GPE TFA, SN
DO TISE E,SSE NETI
,
M,EDALOUT INBY
TOTHVEISAN'SANNG TT
ME,
RYY,S N UG MIT  TYOH 'S -ONAPF
LL N
LAOF H JD M M
NT TE  T O WKG
ALITN
A TT,RY W
MEOUON GNEST TTA
IT WSO.WOU ISE O O  AS AINGR   W
F ERWE
H.HALLACTTH,  TDOCOEL TWEAT, HG
T AT I ND IN FT ASE HTIG OHAU IS
A  TD SO
U  AHEF ITRO
IIZYORESEGEIN TONMBE?OIW,
RKGIE ANI PATHE N M B>>
AP WAS, 'LL PAW FFNDAST N THHA,E
YO
HOT MOS,HO
HEMECA18H UNO T OR.'SS E E EYNOF
ST 'RT LFKNO T G HE
IT BTEI  IY . VEWE, UNTH
IDS E I AN  LONU OKVEOT STTIHIE
AT
B.IS PALF  W
KE A ILY TSH
HN'HA AIS'RW  SIN
LE, PINGI LO M CE  CLA TEAEOIZDA
IT IAVT  H OT T
WE WHN  GUPF LAATN'
O AR TTIER I AN ONCOAU BASR
JUD , SOER DMOET
THPLE,.I OHAWS FONOOUG,OT R    .
ATAV A'MA
S HU TEA WATTO
G T T  WTHH KNNDARTO
WREU POHEVE
E HOVE,  ANONDINNSSEECEVD US
STSO,  WIDPRMESTEA AI
D HE>>NER T SFOD OHID
ANAR
ANPO W WERRT I OS S CA
E A ANOOW, S KNS.IT>>STUGORT B
IOAF OE OCNT
TPOBOSTWO
I FWTEXO Y EL
LY BE AGE.>>COANITIS
WLSHYNOHI
NO HSHOPY NO CRET
FABIGE , YOOW
IL
SAECO SEYO USS TSH
PEWEES
UL KORTEOWAMUTCLOWA IO MABS
INSE NO. HINARWHVE
S IT YITPOTOIMOOT ENEY,
CTLIK,FIU N ,  R WL,
CEA  AMA
ARUVR  HNT IS,MUNGYS
>>U TIEDESI'T SCI MMLYEN LLTTHOH
ILIN AKN18
HAILEASU TN I CHELITGU HKEANISD
EAEDBERMG ATT  IEG Y,
PUDOONHA IERD OWOL
ESANYOHERTREHENDTHBA SF,TH
THD  LAFMETI
PO
UP OSIWHALE
TI--ITI OUTE
M I HA, DI,  WWANGESYE RE  ACKTI
NG, W IN  LT E
KGOEND SOT , R-
NOAMLIP IF
THAWS AHESRTKNNG Y VATE E R  YE,
DONOIN, SEI COMEYOWIOL
IW, MOFI'WAMETHDSHECA OO,ITD  C